all right so today's topic I have a
story I want to show you guys I just
came back from economy show maybe 20
minutes to go here in Montreux and
during the show there's a couple as
being very disruptive at one point the
guy in the couple gets up on the stage
while the comic is bit ass he did it to
both of them she's got up on the stage
now if you don't understand like imagine
you're at a hockey game and some
[ __ ] just jumps on the ice and
he's like what'd you do with the ice
wall did you get thrown out exactly
obviously people at music concerts they
get up on state ticket tackle attack oh
man for life so me I'm already heated at
this point because I'm looking I'm like
yeah what the [ __ ] this is like a safety
issue you can't begin up because if it's
me I'm punching you the show is off to a
weird start okay I grew up third halfway
through my set the lady she's talked to
the person she's with and I hear them
because in the comedy show you can hear
people talking it's a quiet room you're
the only speaking another voice is
easily audible so I'm like hey is
something wrong and they're like yeah
we're not happy with our customer
service I'm like correct that's good
information if you want you feel free to
share it with the staff after the show
during the show you can shut the [ __ ] up
crowd erupts because they're happy
someone's telling to shut the [ __ ] of
course I try to move on with the show
and the lady starts to go
the racist you wanna say so she just
kept repeating this shit's getting old
I'm like what's getting old
check this shit's getting old and listen
I don't like to say stuff is racist
I actually hesitate to do it because
most of the time the conversation is
unproductive because so people who don't
get it
unless it's very flagrant they just
think oh you're it's in your head so for
me I never have that conversation but my
intuition in that moment was like I
think she's getting tired of hearing me
say anything about black people and to
be fair my set has little to do with
black people I barely talked about race
but she does didn't want to hear any of
it so they start to leave for the door
I'm outside on and they come up to me
and they're like hey I'm sorry listen
we're gonna leave but you listen to the
communities that couldn't handle our
[ __ ] I might get the [ __ ] out of here
and go home I just want I'm tired yeah
of course she says listen she goes she
goes and how about you go back to your
[ __ ] country who welfare monkey [ __ ]
you know I did
cuz you know what you know the moment
was [ __ ] I knew is racist yes of course
suggested you was right I was telling
the other comics I'm pretty sure she's a
racist
I like I've been feeling my guns like I
don't know if you can go ahead I'm like
bro I have a good feel yeah of course
and then it happened and my friends
looking like woah [ __ ] you was right
now I'm like that is what most racism in
life is yeah it's a lot of dog whistling
it's you saying stuff that kind of hints
at it but you don't want to be direct
with it and oftentimes black people were
made to feel crazy about stuff we know
is wrong but it's really flaky and this
girl saying all kinds of file-share
about my mom being a monkey and I'm
going on welfare my whole life and I
should go back keep in mind I'm born in
this country served in the military but
to her I had to go back to my country
whatever that means and it just in that
moment I was just so happy I was like
[ __ ] I'm right like my intuition is
still sharp you know to find the face of
Wallace Ace of Base bro
sighs it opened up my eyes I saw the
signs that [ __ ] is crazy saying all of
that [ __ ]
and you understand how much I must have
heard races [ __ ] in my life for me to
care more about the fact that I can
still detect racism yeah than the actual
racism this doesn't matter you gonna say
some raisin [ __ ] like at this point
water under the bridge listen after 37
years in my [ __ ] life the number of
races [ __ ] that I've heard there's more
chance that if you say something really
foul at races to me I'll laugh then I'm
gonna explode right and then people that
always tell me yes people see racism
everywhere listen you don't hear it
because it's not directed to you I
listen let's they said what are you
gonna do you stupid monkey you know what
are you gonna do right she's getting on
with my face I'll bite
I'll be sure to put your face up on
Facebook tonight yeah whatever [ __ ]
yourself so just it anyways we wanted to
share this story with you guys just to
let you guys know about our lived
experience tell us what you guys think
of the comments below we really want
[Music]